تصور ان تحصل على فرصه للحديث مع احبائك
الراحلين سنوات تشارك معهم نجاحاتك
المهنيه حفله تخرجك زواجك وتتلقى منهم
رضوضا في اللحظه وكانها مكالمه فيديو هذا
ما تقدمه ديبران اي اي وهي شركه كوريه
جنوبيه للذكاء الاصطناعي تستخدم التعلم
الالي لمعالجه الصور ومقاطع الافراد
المتوفين لانشاء توام رقمي من الشخص
الراحل يمكنه التفاعل مع الاحياء يجيب على
اسئلتهم ويشارك معهم ذكريات الماضي الشروط
تصوير مقابله مسبقه مع الشخص الراغب في
تطوير نسخه الافتراضيه لها لمده سبع ساعات
يقوم اذا كان اصطناعي بالتعرف على
سلوكياته وانطباعاته واجهه محاكاه طريقه
كلامه ايضا اجعل المحادثات طبيعيه بعد
وفاته تطوير النسخه الافتراضيه يتراوح بين
12 و 24 الف دولار لكن في كل مره ترغب
فيها التحدث مع هذه النسخه الافتراضيه
سيكون عليك ان ت 1200 دولار المزيد معنا
بس
تون تناولتها روايات وافلام الخيال العلمي
عبر السنوات هل سيكون بامكاننا التحدث مع
الموتى بشكل مباشر في يوم من الايام اليوم
يبدو اننا وصلنا المستقبل بالفعل وهناك
العديد من الشركات التي تعمل على تطبيق
الفكره واتاحه التواصل مع الاحباء
الراحلين عبر الهاتف او الفيديو او
لمساعده الصوتي في 2020 صمامه فريق انتاج
وترقيات في كوريا صوره ثلاثيه الابعاد
لطفله توفيت بسبب مرض عضال عندما لجات
والدتها الى الواقع الافتراضي بحثا عن
المواساه وحقق الفيديو مشاهده بالملايين
في جميع انحاء العالم
المساعد الصوتي اليكسا قد يتمكن قريبا من
التحدث اليك باصوات معينه مثل الاصوات
الاقارب المتوفين او حتى المشاهير
الراحلين وهو ما جاء في اعلان نشرته
امازون في يونيو الماضي
خلال العام الماضي وفي الذكرى الخامسه
والثلاثين لوفاتها اجرى برنامج فرنسي
حوارا تلفزيونيا مع الفنانه العالميه
الراحله داليدا بمساعده الذكاء الاصطناعي
تتحدث فيه عن حياتها وبدايتها من الاردن
طرحنا فرضيه وسالنا الناس اذا قالوا لك ان
هناك جهازا تسجل فيه صوتك وافكارك يوميا
ويجعلك تتواصل مع الناس عبر الفيديو بعد
الموت هل يمكن ان تستخدم هذا الجهاز نتابع
الاجابه
[موسيقى]
لا ما بسمع لا ما راح استخدم هذا الجهاز
لانه في اشياء خاصه في ما بحب انه الناس
تعرف عنها مثلا ولو في رساله بدي اوصلها
لحدا اوصلها وانا عايشه وانا ميت
قبل ما يموت الناس
[موسيقى]
اه ممكن ليش لا يعني انه الخبرات الي انا
مريت فيها ممكن حدا يستفيد منها او يعدل
عليها ويمشي بطريقه اسلم واصبح ممكن ورده
يعني
في عندي افكار معينه لكن ما بحب الناس انه
هي بتعرف شو هي افكاري او شو كانت نوايا
او ما هو رايي بالضبط في كل المواضيع يمكن
بحب سجلها نفسي بس اني استخدمها لجهاز انه
وبعدين بالمستقبل في حدا غيري طلع عليه لا
طبعا اكيد ما بحبها يعني
على كل من الرياض ينضم لنا الخبيره
التقنيه عبدالله السابع عبدالله يسعد
صباحك اليوم ودوم اهلا بك من جديد معانا
في صباح العربيه
للحديث او المحادثه مع الموتى من خلال
محادثات او مكالمات افتراضيه نتحدث عن
اليه عملتها بالاول هذه التقنيه
العافيه
واستخدامات مختلفه الشيء اللي قاعد يشوفها
حاليا جدا همم بسيط من استخدامات الذكاء
الاصطناعي من قدره الذكاء الاصطناعي
واستخدام التقنيه المختلفه الموجوده فلذلك
شيء مثل هذا القبيله وشيء جدا همم لكنه
همم لازم نعرف انه كان ايضا ذكاء اصطناعي
صوت الفيديو وغيرها من استخدامات الخطيره
الثانيه فلذلك زي ما نحن فوائد محاسن ايضا
راح يكون لها مشاكل لكن
محاسن الذكاء الاصطناعي فوائده في
المستقبل المستخدمين اكبر من الشيء اللي
احنا ممكن نتصورمات ايش الفرق
بين انه واحد يسجل فيديو قبل ماته وبين
هذه التقنيه هل سيظهر الشخص الافتراضيه
كانه موجود
انتم تقدرون تشتغلون خيالكم تحطون شغلات
كثيره ممكن احنا نستفيد منها الامر اللي
ذكر اليوم هو امر جدا بسيط وسهل جدا همم
يعني ما هو شيء معقد بشكل جدا كبير من
استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي هو توفير بها
افتراضيه وعمل استخدامات معينه
وبعد قليل الصوت لازم نعرف ان هذه مثلا
شيء مدفوع لكن يجب ان تعرفونه مايكروسوفت
على سبيل
المثال تطور خدمه خلال سبع ثواني قادر
النظام الذكاء الاصطناعي من تقليد صوتك ما
للفيديو لمده اسبوع ساعات علشان يقلدون
نبرد صوتك او يوصلون لدرجه الصوت حقتك
فالموضوع بعيد الطور بشكل جدا سريع قاعد
يقدم خدمات اكثر طبعا عبد الله في هذه
التقنيه يتم استنساخ وتقليد تعابير الوجه
يعني الشخص يكون قدامك يحكي كانه هو فعلا
الشخص اللي كان حقيقي
لو رجعنا وقرينا في تقنيه الديب فيك اللي
كانت همم تمشي في تزيين في الاصوات مقاطع
فيديو تقريبا هم يستخدمون مبدا قريب منها
لذلك الموضوع ترى ابعد استخدامات ابعد عن
المدى الطويل وخدمات كثيره ممكن تسويها في
مثال على احد الشركات الان عندها مشروع
همم انت مثلا لو تكلمت باللغه العربيه هذه
اللقاء مثلا كان في اللغه العربيه بامكان
نفس الشركه عن طريق الذكاء الاصطناعي
تغيير اللغه الى اكثر من 17 لغه نفس كل
شيء همم
الخبر او المقابله 19 لغه مختلفه كانك انت
انك انت قاعد تتكلم
الصناعي في حياتنا استخدام التقنيات
الفيديو همم
كبيره خلال سنوات القادمه
الى التقنيه الديب فريك الى اليكسا ما هي
حدود الذكاء الاصطناعي
نتكلم عن شيء قادم في السنوات القادمه
يقدم لك شغلات انت بنفسك ما انت قادر همم
تستوعبها مع تكامل مع تقنيه الطباعه
الثلاثيه الابعاد احنا مقبلين على واقع
مختلف في حياتنا فانت تتكلم عن دكات صناعي
تزييف الحقائق تتكلم عن الدين في تتكلم عن
تقنيه طباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد المستقبل
بصراحه راح يكون مبهر همم طبعا رح يكون
فيه قوانين لاخلاقيات الصناعي وشغلات جدا
كثيره تقلل من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتقدم لنا احنا الفوائد اللي ممكن احنا
نستفيد منها وتغير حياتها طيب الحديث عن
اخلاقي على الاستماع هل يجب ان نخاف اليوم
لهذه التقنيه
كل الانسان لكن تقنيات اذا كان اصطناعي
الفوائد اللي ممكن تقدمها لنا في حياتنا
اكبر من الشيء اللي احنا ممكن نصوره ترى
اذا كان اصطناعي دخوله في حياتنا راح يقدم
فوائد جمه راح يسهل علينا
رح يسوي شغلات احنا ممكن ما نقدر نتصورها
اذا كنا بنتكلم على سبيل المثال قبل 15
سنه وين راح يوصل الجوال وكيف راح يغير
حياتنا وكيف راح نستخدمه في حياتنا بشكل
جدا كبير ما كنا ما راح نتصور هذا الشيء
الان الجوال هو شيء مختلف يعني يقدم كبيره
جدا في حياتنا فلذلك الموضوع ابعد ما احنا
نتصور وابعد ما احنا ممكن نعرف لكن فوائد
اللي راح مستفيد منها في المستقبل الجانب
الطبي من الجانب الامني من الجانب همم همم
المروري وغيرها من استخدامات شيء راح يغير
حياتنا ويقدم لنا شيء جدا مختلف عبد الله
يعني بتقنيه دب فيك لها التقنيه اليوم
يعني فينا المره الجايه نعمل مقابله معك
كانك موجود مستغلين الذكاء الاصطناعي
تقريبا يعني شيء جدا سهل انك ممكن تسويه
ممكن تكون حتى اللقاء باللغه الهنديه لو
سمحت شيء جدا سهل وبسيط همم باستخدام
التقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي عنك يا عبد الله
شكرا جزيلا من الرياض عبد الله السابق